unifying chant blood red stains and
simple yet powerful signage these images
are popping up over and over as
protesters around the world call for
more freedoms in Iran and the downfall
of Iran's government but there is a lot
more to it than what you see in videos
here's a look at some of the history and
symbolism Behind These popular protest
actions and slogans which continue to
spread around the world
women life freedom
this phrase has been chanted at
demonstrations since the death of Masa
amini she's the young Iranian who died
in police custody after allegedly
disrespecting the Islamic Republic's
strict dress code for women now people
are using it in hashtags and in all
kinds of languages but the most notable
version is the Kurdish version
[Applause]
Jin Jian Azadi that's because the slogan
has Kurdish roots and amini whose
Kurdish name was Gina was an ethnic curd
Ava Houma a Kurdish Iranian author told
me that the slogan traces back to the
Kurdish Freedom Movement and the idea
that a country can't be free until its
women are free it's been chanted by
female Kurdish Fighters
and she says it represents Decades of
resistance by Kurdish women against both
state oppression and their own
patriarchy now the slogan is appearing
all over the world and the fact that it
has taken off across ethnicities and
borders and religions is what analysts
say makes this movement so strong
then there's women's hair in Iran women
aren't allowed to show their hair in
public hair and the hijab a hair
covering have been at the heart of the
protests from the very beginning footage
on social media shows women across Iran
removing their hijabs and even cutting
their hair off in public
[Applause]
experts say there are a few key things
to understand here part of this is about
control for decades women in Iran have
been subject to strict dress codes and
restrictions on all kinds of activities
iranian-american psychologist Tara
amrani says that by revealing and
cutting their hair women in Iran are
making a statement that they are taking
back control of their bodies and their
lives
the act of defiance has caught on and
women around the world have been doing
it in solidarity until the woman of Iran
are free we are going to stand
life freedom but there's a historical
and mythological aspect of this too
history Professor Abbas amanat told me
that it dates back thousands of years to
a myth that was put into writing in the
shaname the iconic Persian epic which is
kind of like Iran's Iliad and odyssey
when one of the most iconic characters
is killed his wife cuts off her hair and
ties it around her waist as a sign of
struggle and mourning she then goes on
to avenge her husband's death some of
the experts I talked to say there are a
lot of parallels between that story and
what's happening today women are cutting
their hair to mourn a tragic loss and
also to rise up and demand Justice and
finally there are references to blood
everywhere people have stained their
hands their faces their clothing and
their signs in protest of the Iranian
regime which has cracked down hard on
the demonstrators but protesters aren't
just suggesting that blood is on the
hands of the regime in Persian culture
blood is also a sign of martyrdom for
example during the iran-iraq war a
fountain at a cemetery in Tehran was
dyed red to memorialize the martyrs
after the death of Masa amini iconic
fountains around Tehran were dyed red
again this time by an anonymous artist
Atlantic Council Iran specialist Holly
dogress tweeted today The Fountains were
dyed because of the blood spilled by
Iran's Security Forces at a university
protesters with stained red hands
gathered around another stained red
Fountain and sang an old Iranian song
commemorating martyrs
tulips have bloomed from the blood of
the Youth of the country Holly told me
they're singing that song to suggest
that more protesters will rise up as
more blood is shut and as protesters
marked the 40th Day since amini's death
they evoked blood to call for the
overthrow of Iran's supreme leader
chanting this is the year of blood
foreign
[Applause]
the Iranian government has blamed
foreign enemies for fueling the protests
and has warned young people not to go
into the streets
[Music]
so far the government has charged
hundreds of people in Iran with crimes
in connection with the protests